well I work with scenes but it was David
to Dan's idea you know I mean we're
reaching in the point we already have
the largest tested in television and
we've ever wanted to catch in the
history of television
at least the large casts of regulars and
speaking parts and so forth and it's so
you know the one thing about these
actors is they all of them demand to be
paid and some of our audiences not you
guys if you guys will read the books and
the people read the books have a good
grounding but particularly the audience
that hasn't read the books is already
having trouble following some of the
relations between the families and who's
related to who and all that stuff so
David Mann had made a number of
decisions along the way to simplify
matters and they felt that having
Roberts you know have all these
surviving bastards scattered around
might be a little much you know there
are not I think in the books they're
actually like five bastard's kicking
around I mean there's besides Gendry and
entered storm there's the girl in the
and you know there's the the what may be
the the horror and the the brothel and
some accept and so forth so they decided
to it would be easy to combine Gentry
and entered storm into one one partner
and you know for similar reason is
something like the creation of character
Alton Lannister was because they thought
it would be very complicated like who
exactly feel sprained was he was afraid
but he's a little Anna stir and what its
relation is and you know among an
audience it's already having trouble
keeping the phrasing Lannisters straight
in the family so you know we've made the
number of is measures to simplify things
you know I think you lose something
whenever you do that but on the other
hand we're not losing our audience was
that we don't want to lose
a way of saying what you know it's too
complicated I can I needed to follow so
it's it's all objective closer yeah for
sure
I'd like to read another duncan eggs
story
are there any coming up none immediately
coming up but you know I want to write
more and but I have only seven things
one by one I've been if you don't you
follow my blog might not of Walt will
then I talked about a little monkeys on
my back a lot of monkeys on my back in
recent years I think about five years
ago maybe even further back than that I
said yes too often I have to learn to
say no I've been practicing staying
though - whether it's two projects being
offered me or two conventions though me
to come and speak or whatever too much
yes and left little ever right but one
by one I've been delivering these
monkeys and I'm down to fewer monkeys
eventually when I get winds of winter
done then maybe I have time to write
another dog you think so I I wanted to
want to write about five or six more
kid
yes yes our vulgar phrasing is in the
the best really well I suppose an award
roses some of your kits I mean Henry if
it was pretty cool guy but come on you
get into fourth Edward the fourth and
then Richard the third
who is framed it wasn't a hunch fact
that you're never with an arm don't
believe this in a parking lot of
cinnamon is